hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe
sportfreunde es ist kaum zu glauben aber
wir wissen mittlerweile beim fünfzehnten
workout angelangt das heißt die drei
trainingswochen machen wir mit heute von
der inhalt von jetzt ist ein
militärisches training da gary ist da
eben dollar peter und wir haben heute
wieder einen spezialgast dabei den
choral mario sei sei ein militärischer
fünfkämpfer ein sehr erfolgreicher
internationaler athlet wenn man sie nur
als ein beispiel als herausgreift
zweiter platz 2018 bei der
weltmeisterschaft in der hindernisbahn
staffel also mario gut ab aber stell dir
bitte kurz selbst vor ich bin da mario
been militärischer fünfkämpfer und jetzt
noch für die das vielleicht nicht kennen
das ist zu einem das schießen dann die
internet barn ziel und weitwurf vierte
disziplin ist das hindernisschwimmen und
fünfte disziplin und unser abschluss ist
dann der acht kilometer geländelauf ok
danke mal das heißt noch vier
disziplinen die ich schon mal sehr
fordernd sein noch acht kilometer im
gelände laufen was dann dort eine
rekorde
was kann man sich darunter vorstellen
beim geländelauf ja dann noch nicht da
wo es sein sollte okay aber die ersten
vier disziplinen bin ich glaube ich
meistens ganz gut mit dabei aber ich
habe leute gehört also acht kilometer im
gelände unter 30 minuten und er sagt er
ist noch nicht dort wo er sein wo also
jetzt kann sie damals selbst ein
bisschen ein orden und vergleichen also
das ist schon mal sehr schnell wenn auch
richtig für dich du möchtest noch
schneller werden noch erfolgreicher
werden ja war super bleibt bei so viel
sportarten überhaupt zeit irgendwas
anderes zu machen
das kommt bei uns natürlich ganz auf
diese sonder also während der saison
werden der wettkampfphase ist immer so
ein trägt ja ich bin fünfkampf training
dass er doch für euch disziplin wieder
ins nichts als nix aber im winter
schauen wir natürlich dass man dann
schon die so allgemeiner verlaub
volleyball basketball spielen konnte zum
ausgleich aber super also wir haben
einen groben einblick in der
militärischen fünfkampf bekommen
jetzt legen wir los mit dem aufwärmen
lehre du bist bereit ja magath sehr gut
das wollte ich hören dann legen wir los
fange an stadtlauf dynamisches bewegen
wir steigern das ganze natürlich
befangen locker an und dann irgendwann
werden wir dann richtig intensiv richtig
aufgewärmt sein und auch das aufgewärmte
formal dann wieder ein richtiger
intensiven trainingsprogramm
auch drauf auch da natürlich kennt die
varianten knie heben an felsen immer
wieder einmal was zwischendrin einbauen
und ich gehe davon aus maria auch die
fünfkämpfer mobilisieren
bevor sie mit einer intensiven einheit
loslegen ja darauf gefahren war der
hindernis war natürlich sehr wichtig
entstehen landung ansprüchen auch viele
sprünge hohe hohe sprünge tiefe
landungen da muss man schon richtig
bereit sind okay dann hätte gesagt
machen wir das einmal aus lockern
ausschnitt und die beine
ich würde vorschlagen nachdem gestern
unten begonnen haben zu mobilisieren
fangen wir einmal roman oder
halswirbelsäule sich gut und wir starten
mit lockeren kreisen nur halbkreisen von
einer schulter zu anderen genau nach den
halbkreisen baumann klar wieder ein wir
blicken nur links wechsel auf rechts
japan hin und her
wie bist du zum fünfkampf kommen maria
bei mir das ganze angefangen als ich auf
der villa gegen wiener neustadt gewesen
bin okay da bin ich dann einfach mal
meine religiösen nach oben und nach
unten eingeteilt worden
zudem bereichs meisterschaften ok habe
mich dann auch qualifiziert für die der
us meisterschaften und nach dem speed
ihn ganz gut gelaufen ist hab es dann
nach zwei erreicht geben als danach zwei
an kassen du könntest dass man versuchen
das zum herzsport reinkommst das habe
ich dann auch versucht und letztendlich
geschafft und als sie nicht
leistungssportler aus leistungssportler
seit vielen jahren tage und wo sind die
leistungssportler die fünfkämpfer wir
sehen dem haus c 11 ins system stellen
okay dann wechseln wir wieder in die
dynamik das heißt gab hampelmann ist
genauso übung dem alle kennen alle
wissen springt ihr handeln bevor es auf
den hintern isbank dass weniger eher
weniger was macht ihr hauptsächlich
einlaufen dann sprungübungen schon zur
vorbereitung für die ganze landungen
okay das wäre dann klar machen basieren
organisieren dass mit dem einlaufen ist
eine schwierige man wieder sportteil der
wie klingt es noch hin aber die
zuschauer zu hause natürlich im
wohnzimmer ist ein rechtlich ist das
nicht so lustig da im kreis zu laufen
deswegen schauen wir heute dass man mit
alternativen übungen genau so das herz
kreislauf system in schwung bringen
ok heiße visuelle hammer als nächstes
nehmen was ich zu sagen die ganze weile
ganze wirbelsäule gut so der fachmann
aus der gestreckten position wir bei für
wirbel abholen bevor du loslegst dafür
bieten drehst du die 90 grad zur kamera
peter johe frontal dass sie immer beide
varianten also wir starten von oben
beginnend und waren dann wie überspielte
über nach unten bis man beim internet
gelangt sind und waren wir die leute
schön langsam und konzentriert und
wieder nach oben bieber fieber bis man
in einer komplette strecke position und
wieder schön mit dem finger nach unten
anderen
ok also die wirbelsäule wird das so
vorstellen
die dämpfe man natürlich jeden sprung ab
das heißt die arbeitet auf der
hindernisbahn im dauerbetrieb könnte man
sagen oder ganz genau wie viele
hindernisse hat die hindernisbahn 20
internet die kinder verteilt 500 meter
länge 20 hindernisse jetzt ist natürlich
die frage drängt sich auf was ist der
rekord zwei minuten 24 24 leute wo wir
zusammen aus also das ist richtig
richtig schnell
ok dann locker mal aus lauf mal am stand
der roxeler für dich mal probiert das
roxeler für wörrstadt gut aus das war
die beste zeit auf der hindernisbahn
okay aber pro jahr alles her okay aber
nichtsdestotrotz unter drei minuten ist
schon mal wirklich top zeit dank ist
privat boxen mario dass das jetzt nur
ortschaft und damit noch mehr trainiert
ganz genau solches mittwoch mit
trainiert okay sie ärgert nur dann geht
natürlich durch einiges weiter ok aus
lockern wir mobilisieren weiter wir
brauchen einmal die schultergelenke und
die eltern gelenke das heißt mit klasse
schon mal an kreis und vorwärts und
rückwärts beginnen mal mit vorwärts und
rückwärts kreisen und gegen gleich an
und richtungswechseln album seitlich
hoch geben unterarme kreisen
wie kann man sie das hindernisschwimmen
vorstellen was passiert bei uns source
50 meter vier hindernisse ok bei denen
es dann zum teil und drüber sprechen
bringen abspringen bvk den sprung und
lauf wird auch ok wahnsinn ja also da
braucht man nicht nur entsprechende
dynamik im wasser seien große lunge
glaube ich dass man entsprechend die
luft als sie ein teil der marke ok dann
locker mal wieder aus eine dynamische
übung aufwärmen einer dynamischen
übungen ich hätte noch eine übung die
sehr wichtig ist für die abschaffung
gelenke bis hüfte auch hier bietet das
feld unseres was der quasi perfekt wie
möglich ein paar paralleler stand wie es
ganz nach unten
in ansätzen wie aber soll er muss nicht
gerade bleiben und dann schieben wir die
knie gerade nach vorne
möglichst in richtung boden und
versuchen das ausbalancieren
gleichgewicht halten genau steuern nach
vorhergehenden zurückgehen wird eine
volle beweglichkeit aus dem sprunggelenk
heraus zu arbeiten das kniegelenk arbeit
in sicht gelenk arbeit also unteren
extremität wird der muskulär belastet
und entsprechend auf eine sprung
belastung im nachhinein auch vorbereitet
und da gibt es dann noch die variante
bereits stark entnehmen wir die zweite
gerade dazu breit das selber nur dieses
mal mehr auf die oberschenkel innenseite
auf die adduktoren parker und wir haben
wieder aus dem sprunggelenk nach oben
ausbalancieren versuchen die fersen hoch
zu heben und nicht unbedingt mit dem
hintern hoch zu kommen
genau wie wichtig ist es die fersen
hochhebt bevor man im allgemeinen
aufwärmen abschließen hettich sagt
stephan flock kann man mal das hat
kabinett nur schwierig ausgeschaut ja
das ist wirklich anstrengend
ok dann ihrerseits aufschalten ihr seid
alles klar
wenn ich sage 4 x 7 was kommt
das sieben ja ja ja bitte
angesagte über wichtig ist military
fitness bedeutet hohe körperliche
belastung ihr müsst das muskulär
entsprechend vorbereiten weil es zu
verletzungen kommen kann
und das braucht man gar nicht ich sage
jetzt mal drei wochen geschafft und die
nächsten trainingseinheiten kriegen das
sicherlich eine perfekte und wenn ihr
immer mit dabei sein und welche immer
gut aufwärts voller belastung dann ist
das überhaupt kein problem
dann ist er danach eine hohe belastung
für den körper absolut aushaltbar letzte
übung noch rücken aufrichten das heißt
bau klage pop zusammen zwicken füße sind
am boden und den oberkörper loslösen los
heben hochziehen nicht mit schwung
arbeiten sondern mit der muskelkraft
arbeiten
das ist aber vielleicht nix nix
ok wenn fertig dann aufstehen kurz
durchschütteln
aber braucht man nur was dynamisches das
heißt hier bewegt sich am stand ihr
läuft zum stand und auf meinen
startsignal wird sie schnell gelaufen
und auf stoppsignal einfach wieder
langsam weiter laufen und stopp stopp
stopp stopp und ausloggen sage ich
wünsche euch bereit
trinken guter plan das was wir jetzt
machen
ihr kennt das system 30 sekunden eine
übung 30 sekunden pause das nutzen wir
haben leichte übung vorzustellen zu
erklären
ihr kennt das er durch probieren damit
durch üben und danach gehen wir in den
belastungszeugen 20 sekunden belasten
zehn sekunden pause und das ganze dann
zwar durchgänge das heißt zwei mal vier
minuten volle belastung im anschluss
erste übung eidechse der it sagst du mir
bitte vor breite liegestütz griff und
während dem runtergehen in den
liegestütz das linke und das rechte knie
wechselweise zum ellbogen vorziehen
die etwas einfachere variante wand gehen
sollte mosley gestützt und sieht nur den
ellbogen links und rechts nach vor so
wie es für euch am besten passt mal auf
die bitten ausgangsposition in 20
sekunden staat mehr los 30 sekunden
liegestütz mit knie links und rechts zum
album vorbringen zehn sekunden
manga/spanien drinnen da kommt man im
aussage sind konzentration wie vor dem
hindernis beim lauf glaube so ein tolles
geht's
das einerseits natürlich die oberen
extremität die arme die trainiert und
andererseits natürlich die
rumpfmuskulatur die damit dabei
seitlichen bauchmuskulatur
da wird ganz viel in dieser komplexen
übung trainiert sekunden oder sagen wir
30 schon wieder vorbei und kurz
auslagern aufstehen mario beim schießen
auf welche distanz schießt ihr großes
200 meter okay kommt aber auch auf die
nation zu erfahren das heißt wir noch
wettkämpfe wo man dann auf 300 meter
schießt ok mit anderen punktevergabe und
kleinkaliber kommt auch vor dass es gibt
teile varianten
er kann auch oliver kleinkaliber ja bis
zu 300 meter also dass ein statist an
tzen
da bin ich froh wenn ich das tue sie
muss ich ganz ehrlich dazu sagen okay
die zweite übung die man machen handels
oder auch crunches mit rotation aus den
oberkörper heraus das heißt eine übung
für den bauch das heißt in die position
kniewinkel fersen am boden hochziehen
linke album rechtes knie rechte ellbogen
linkes knie im wechsel
erkennst übung versucht sie in den 30
sekunden eine hohe frequenz zu fahren
und so viel übungen so viele
wiederholungen wie möglich in die übung
hineinzupacken in fünf sekunden gehts
los
nach 21
auch muskulatur leiten wir führen
fünfkämpfer wichtig bei
unterschiedlichsten belastungen sondern
generell für euch zu hause stark ehrung
starke bauchmuskulatur erleichtert mir
meinen alltag extrem mal ganz viel
belastung darauf kommt und jeder kraft
transfer von der unteren auf die obere
und umgekehrt extremität natürlich da
unterstützt wird
nach zwei sekunden rotbach abgeschlossen
kurz durchschnaufen
marie bäumer angesprochen auf der
hindernisbahn 20 hindernisse extrem hohe
hindernisse was ist das höchste
hindernis die fünf meter lang fünf meter
hohe leiter obendrüber um drüber und
meistens springen und meist springen das
heißt du springst dann von fünf meter ab
genau das ist richtig hoch das bieten
etwa haben ausprobieren das muss man
natürlich vorbereiten da muss man
richtig landen können dann muss man
richtig gehofft in den oberschenkeln und
in den beinen haben man muss sehr gut
sehen sie motorisch aufgestellt sein
dass man das ausgleichen kann sollte
jegliche belastung seien technisch muss
man natürlich können und das
heruntergebrochen für euch zwei übungen
variante nummer eins boxfans variante
nummer zwei der hochsprung gerät sagt
euch einmal den box stand vor aus einer
position hoch durchstrecken absteigen
nicht hinunter springen wir steigen ab
aber so können wir mal die muskulatur
trainieren
die madonna brauchen und mario hat eine
variante der hochsprung genau mario aus
die hände in der hüfte wenn das
gleichgewicht technisch nicht möglich
ist kann das natürlich auch weg geben
aber das ist natürlich zweite variante
die man perfekt umsetzen kann
vorbereiten in 15 sekunden statt mal los
dritte übung box champ sehen sekunden
nur drei sekunden bereit und los geht's
30 sekunden arbeiten
teilzeitkraft einläuten 30 sekunden
diese übung bedeutet feuer am
oberschenkel ich sowohl beim wegspringen
wie auch beim landen
das ist intensiv und anstrengend nach
zehn sekunden noch 52 das durch 30
sekunden musik das ist schon ganz schön
anstrengend maler sowohl bei dir wir bei
der lehre also diese dynamische
belastung dynamische bewegung im
gesamten körper quasi die fordert schon
richtig und ich werde das ansehen das
wird nicht weniger vierte übung wir
selbst sind gleich eine dynamik drauf
aber diesmal im stand live mit knie
heben das knie hebel auf oder auch miet
ulb das heißt volle dynamik kniehoch so
richtig 30 sekunden belasten aber jetzt
noch mal kurz durchschnaufen
ich muss immer ein bisschen warten bis
meine trainingspartner dort quasi city
die atmung besser reguliert dass die
wieder zu kräften kommen weil dann ist
das für mich ein gutes zeichen dass ihr
damaliger staaten kennt und dann passt
es zehn sekunden
die hebel auf teilt sich die
geschwindigkeit auch hier ein wenn wir
vollgas gibt während lange 30 sekunden
los geht's
noch 20 sekunden macht sie so hitz
training training training
in der bewegung verständlich die antwort
kurz und knapp ja ist mit dabei schauen
wir mal in der pause auch man dann hat
dieser mehr aus erlebten kennen aber in
der bewegung nicht drinnen
zur 16 kurz durchschnaufen
das sind die vier übungen sieht man
jetzt mit euch machen 20 sekunden
belasten zehn sekunden pause und das
ganze in zwei durchgängen mit jeweils
wir sind zweimal vier übungen und dann
haben wir schon wieder hoch intensive
belastung hinter uns jetzt bitte macht
mir auch ja aber hits trainings schon
bei uns im grunde das was auf der
hinterbank okay jetzt mal richtige
intervall erlaufen
okay das heißt der klassische
speedtraining intervalltraining auf der
hindernisbahn befasst sich ein paar
hindernisse heraus gibt vollgas darüber
kurze pause wieder wieder wieder genau
bis zum erbrechen quasi ich habe die
mannschaft also was luftig anstrengend
wird dann wehrt sich der körper
teilweise dagegen okay leute wie es an
vier übungen lang zweimal für übungen
achtmal 2010 bedeutet vier minuten
höchste belastung dann noch mal zwei
minuten pause und das ganze manchmal
zweimal das heißt jetzt sammelt all eure
energie des haupt in die erste übung in
den eidechsen gang eidechsen liegestütz
20 sekunden
volle power wir starten in 30 sekunden
macht sich bereit vorbereiten nicht nur
den körper den hammer vorbereitet auch
den kopf der muss wissen welche
belastung kommt jetzt stellt sich darauf
ein dann ist dann das umsetzen
eigentlich schon for soft oder gary
wenn der kopf dabei ist der körper macht
sowieso dann mit wir starten in sehen
sie konnten bereitmachen noch 52
21 sekunden für euch zu hause
klassische liegestütze oder in der
ausgangsposition das knie zum album
ziehen beides gut halbzeit ich schon
geschafft nach 21 20 sekunden durch
zweite übung bauch übung auf die matte
noch 321 hohe geschwindigkeit hohes
bewegungs tempo richtig anstrengen
richtig belasten
ihr könnt natürlich die an die arme
variieren ausstrecken vor der brust
haben bei der schläfe haben so steuert
er die belastung natürlich auch in 321
sei das aussehen sie konnten
ich glaube der mikrofon muss man kurz
richten am herzen wir gerne bereit
machen so richtig noch kurz ein und
götschl aus popstars & hawkes sprünge
halbzeit ist schon wieder vorbei fünf
sekunden nach 21 beide aus lockern
ich weiß es geht wieder los in ein paar
sekunden knie hebel auf hohe
geschwindigkeit 30 kunden nach 21 uhr
los geht's jetzt haben wir zwar
körperlich wirklich hoch belasteten
kreislauf belastungen hintereinander
da klatschen wirklich was dazu dass auch
so durchzuziehen noch zehn sekunden 321
und sommer durch ersten vier übungen
seien erledigt zweiter durchgang
ausgangsposition eidechsen gang 21 und
los geht's und er setzt dieser transfer
ist auch hier erkennbar
eidechsen die gestützt bewegen im
gelände je näher dem feind desto näher
dem boden bist du schön hast diese
bewegung braucht der soldat genauso wie
als andere das heißt ein gutes mittel
und entsprechend auch den einsatz zu
trainieren
zwei sekunden eine und zehn sekunden
pause wir wechseln sofort auf die bauch
übung noch 54 32 algerischer bereiten
geht's los
ich habe das hat doppelt motiviert weise
einen jungen dynamischen
trainingspartner hat aber da war heute
dagegen da gibt da richtig gescheit gas
natürlich das militärische fitness ist
ein heimspiel für die ich gerne
zwei sekunden eine frau 19 sekunden
station wechsel box chips und boxt
rücksprünge bereitmachen 21 uhr los
geht's kontrolliert absteigen wenn ich
irgendwo war auf springt runter springen
ja kontrolliert ist absteigen oder die
streck sprünge achtet auf eure beinachse
dass die flaschen parallel bleiben fünf
sekunden satz zur zeit zehn sekunden
noch einmal alles zusammen nehmen was
diesmal knie hebel auf 33 21 uhr los
geht's können eltern zum knie und
umgekehrt
der oberkörper bleibt aufrecht das heißt
der kniehoch muss wirklich gut sein
nach fünf sekunden gleich satz durch 321
hause durchschnaufen hin und hergehen
ein und ausatmen
wir machen jetzt zwei minuten serien
pause satzpause da kann der kreislauf
sie einmal bisher holen der kammer an
schluck trinken das funktioniert und wir
sehen beim springen wir haben schon
gesagt nicht nur auf der hindernisbahn
ist der transfer zum soldaten da es ist
also im häuserkampf wenn man irgendwo in
ahaus rein will raus will man braucht
die power aus den oberschenkel aus den
strecken um irgendwohin aufzuspringen
man braucht die stabilität beim hinunter
springen
das seien als zubringer leistungen für
den einsatz soldaten und dafür
trainieren wir mit und auch wie eben
diese einsatzsoldaten mal dein lieblings
disziplinen haben kehrt im militärischen
fünfkampf ist der wurf wurde genau wie
kann man sich das vorstellen wie wie
schaut es aus wie ist also distanzen
also grundsätzlich werfen mir vor einer
steinmauer die etwa in brusthöhe ist das
heißt man kann nicht übertreten
man kann nicht meckern übertreten ok und
nur indem man über dem überfliegen
ok also wenn man über die markt ist aber
davon gemeinsam eine raus ja okay man
nicht aus aber man kommt schon von weit
wurf wirklich optimal
ja das ist klar und wie weit geht es
dann wäre es erst das in zielwurf das
sind insgesamt 16 würfe ja auf 16
jeweils einen grafen attrappen ja genau
wo ich sagen okay und dann noch drei
würfe verdienen dann erweitert was sagen
so die weitesten distanzen die da
geworfen werden das weiteste was zum
beispiel bei der letzten wm war machen
72 meter ok also 2 70 meter ist wird
seine songs vorstadt ganzes fußballfeld
aber von 16 dazu 16 da geht es einmal
aus oder oder knapp darüber
und das ist schon richtig weit ja und
das ist ja wie schwer ist auch
handgranaten 550 gramm 550 gramm also
das ist ja mal ein fußballplatz
ausprobieren wie weit dass man selber
kommt das gab es über 30 meter ist schon
mal ganz gut oder
ja wenn es vorbei ist dann nicht wenn
man international vorn mit dabei sein
wird dann wird man schon wahrscheinlich
50 meter plus werfen müssen und sie ja
genau werfen beim zielwurf aber sagen
wir für uns normalsterbliche otto
normalverbraucher preis meter wenn das
drinnen ist sagen wir schon wirklich gut
dabei garrett ist einigermaßen
regeneriert hat sich gut erholt da gerne
bereit ist dann muss ja jeder bereit
sein weil das ist ein motivator nummer
eins und der hat es noch nie eine an
ausscheiden durchgang durch ein zweiter
durchgang vollgas in zehn sekunden start
macht wenn man bereits dann geht's los
darf man nicht so lange warten fünf
sekunden 321 motto es wird schon wieder
gewaltvolle paar bei euch zu hause bei
uns da in der sporthalle acht
wiederholungen also acht durchgänge mit
je 20 sekunden belasten die ersten zehn
sekunden lang schaufeln
der tschechische arbeiten arbeiten
arbeiten arbeiten
tyson tyson 21 uhr aufstehen zehn
sekunden also kein wechsel auf die
ausübung in die rückenlage bereitmachen
3 2 1
ja aber bauchmuskulatur volle belastung
auch hier halbzeit zehn sekunden nur
noch 5 3 2 1 und durch aufstehen box
tops & hawkes wegspringen teilzeitkraft
120 sekunden
und das ist natürlich auch für mario
extreme herausforderung extreme
belastung der städte in der vorbereitung
auf die neue saison nimmt sie die zeit
und trainiert mit uns aber trainiert hat
natürlich spezifisch auf der
hindernisbahn ganz anders das heißt für
ihn ist die belastung sehr hoch und aus
zehn sekunden pause und vielleicht
wieder rein wie hebel auf 21 uhr los
geht's aber gerade beim laufen und beim
knie hebel auf glaube wir kriegen ganzen
guten drinks transfer hinauf die auch
kilometerzeit deshalb vorne gemacht und
der maler fliegt quasi über die über die
piste noch 5 sekunden
viermal noch eidechsen liegestütz gary
geht schloss sowie gebracht so extreme
stabilität in der schulter erst die
belastung der aushalten der körper
arbeitet darauf runter die knie kommen
links und rechts nach vor
das hilft der sie das becken bleibt so
gut wie es geht gerade der kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und 20
sekunden volle power belastung ist aus
zehn sekunden wechsel auf die grunge
hundreds 321 sammler bereit los geht's
jawohl der wirtschaft da wird schwitzt
das ist auch super sache zehn sekunden
nur 321 10 aus aufstehen rockstars
niederelbe die letzten zwei übungen
besser man eine chance dass nochmals auf
jetzt was drinnen hat in zwei eins los
geht's zwar kennt natürlich ein bisschen
variieren
man nehme ganz so viel energie da ist
dann springt zeit geht es mit den decken
nicht ganz so weit runter bei den
sprüngen beziehungsweise springt nicht
ganz so hoch irgendwohin auf aber volle
belastung ist dennoch da drei sekunden
noch 2 1 und 10 sekunden durchschnaufen
letzte übung mario letzten übung gern
bereit machen so ist einfach nie
hochheben l vom hoch genau nach zehn
sekunden letzten zehn sekunden vom
workout endspurt quasi eins ausschlafen
ausgehen bewegt sich nach vorn bewegt
euch zurück
lockert die muskulatur aus drinks ein
schluck bleibt aber in bewegung ja jetzt
nicht niederlegen zusammenklappen und
den kreislauf sagen es ist wo es aus
nahe stehen bleiben bewegen ja das ist
zum regenerieren zum wieder runterkommen
perfekt mara wss bereichen auch der
hintern s-bahn wenn ihr durchs ziel renz
bewegt so echt aus
ja genau laktat ohne ende als unliebsam
körper ohne ende da musst du in dem vor
der ganze körper weil der ganze körper
belastet ist aber ich glaube noch an
kurzen um vor allem über der ziellinie
wird geschaut dass man auf ausläuft
genau dass man wieder regeneriert und
genau das ist es was meinst du auch nur
kurz bewegen kurz ausschüttung cancer
gern darunter spazieren gehen dass die
hohe belastung besser verdaut also
deshalb als varianten immer dann ganz
gut hingekriegt okay
dann würde ich vorschlagen zumal die aus
und einatmen körper aufrichten
sauerstoff hinein lassen und wieder
ausatmen jeder in seinem rhythmus jeder
in seinem tempo alle sportler fremd zu
trainieren mit einer hohen belastung
mario oder was sonst noch sagen wohin
die unterbrochen durch das fleisch
richtig sagte wir sind natürlich jetzt
auch mit einem training der vorbereitung
die muslime seien vielleicht schon vor
ermüdet und schwer
daher legt man vielleicht mit zwei
trainingstage rein bevor man ganz genau
zum workout kommt das heißt die
belastung war da das war jetzt eine
zusätzliche belastung für dieses
training da wie gesagt schaden wird
sicher nicht und für euch zu hause ist
als die ganze woche bereits brach am
trainieren gewesen heute der grünen der
abschluss hohe intensive belastung jetzt
ins wochenende hineingehen regenerieren
an die frische luft gehen spazieren
gehen runter laufen gehen jawohl
da wollen wir hin das passt gut der ard
gesagt gut dann machen wir eine übung
noch zum auslaufen das heißt auf die
matte hinsetzen beine anwinkeln für sie
leicht öffnen und links und rechts hin
und her pendelt mit den beinen die knie
am boden herunter
da kriegt man bislang belastung aus der
lendenwirbelsäule hinaus also zuerst
einmal aus lockern und dann links und
rechts zum boden hinunter
mutter
meine lieben zu hause eine halbe stunde
workout eine halbe stunde training haben
wir wieder geschafft haben wir wieder
abtrainiert sozusagen militärisch
fitnesstraining mit hoher körperlicher
belastung ist erledigt jetzt wie gesagt
selbständig noch etwas regenerieren
spazierengehen runde locker auslaufen
runde das wären dinge die jetzt dem
körper wirklich gut und um mit energie
und elan dann ins wochenende zu gehen
wir freuen uns auf euch auf montag und
wünschen euch ein schönes wochenende
und wie gesagt bis montag auf die
nächste einheit